Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, baseball legend
and business heavy hitter
Alex Rodriguez joins the Tank.
I love people
who have a PhD.
I mean "poor, hungry,
and driven."
I'm a Pro Bowl
running back.
Wow.
They say
think like a millionaire,
hustle like you're broke.
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
That's what
I'm talking about!
Dun, dun, dun!
That's a horrible thing
to say!
What if I told you
that you could look like this?
[ Gasps ]
Oh!
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Holy God!
Marquez: I grew up
in Vallejo, California,
a pretty challenging
neighborhood.
My father
was a single parent
who hustled
day in and day out
to provide
for my sister and I.
I stayed active and out
of trouble by playing sports.
My father was my coach
who pushed me
to be the best person
I could.
Ondrea:
Marquez and I met online,
and fitness
is one of the things
that really
brought us together.
When we first met,
we loved going for hikes,
going for runs.
We really bond
over staying active.
One day, I was on the bike
looking at my phone,
looking at food.
An idea popped up.
Let's making something
not healthy, healthy.
Two months later,
we rented a commercial kitchen,
got engaged.
Oh, you're such
a good boy.
And we're new parents.
We just welcomed our baby boy,
Mason, to the world.
Marquez and I have both
given up our careers,
and we've really put
everything on the line for this.
We were able to bring Marquez's
dad on full‐time, as well.
Owning our own business
can be really scary
and challenging
with a new baby,
but we know
that we're doing this
for the right reasons ‐‐
for our family.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Ondrea.
And my name
is Marquez.
We're from the Bay Area
in Northern California,
and our company
is called...
The Dough Bar.    The Dough Bar.
We are seeking $300,000
for 15% equity in our company.
Sharks, what do you think
you would look like
if you ate doughnuts
every day?
[ Cuban laughs ]
What if I told you
that you could eat
our Dough Bar doughnuts
every single day
and look like this?
Oh!
Corcoran:
Oh, my God!
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Whoo!
Holy God.
[ Laughter ]
This is Dan Ziegler,
our friend and all‐natural
professional body builder.
He's able
to maintain this physique
and still get his fix because
he eats Dough Bar doughnuts,
which are
protein‐packed doughnuts.
[ Laughs ]
They're baked, not fried,
low in fat, sugar deprived,
plus each doughnut is packed
with 11 grams of protein,
including the hole.
Hmm.
We make eating
these healthy treats easy.
You go online,
you place your orders,
and they're shipped
directly to your door,
individually packaged.
Simply store them
in the fridge or freezer
and pop them in the microwave
when it's time to eat.
So, Sharks,
who wants a sample?
Herjavec: All right.
Greiner: Yeah,
we want a lot of them.
Less talk,
more eating!
[ Greiner laughs ]
Come on!
He's coming,
Barb.
[ Laughter ]
Marquez:
All right.
Oh, my God.
Herjavec: Thank you.
And what's that?
Ondrea: Yeah, help yourselves
to this.
This is a box
of our doughnuts.
Thank you, sir.
So you have two doughnuts.
They're freshly glazed,
already prepped for you.
Thank you,
dear.
You're welcome.
[ Laughter ]
Marquez: So you have
two of our top sellers.
We have our apple‐pie doughnut,
as well as
our cookie‐butter doughnut
topped with chocolate crackers.
Oh!
Corcoran: Mmm.
Rodriguez: Mmm.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
So one question
we want you to ask yourself is,
"Would you rather have
a protein bar or one of these?"
How many calories?
So, with the doughnut glaze,
it's about 200 calories.
The doughnut itself
is 150 calories.
It's very tasty.
Marquez: Awesome.
It's chewy,
which I like.
It reminds me
almost of a cross between
a bagel
and a doughnut.
Yes.
Well‐said.
Do you sell them
without the glaze?
Marquez: So,
part of the beauty is
we send our doughnuts to you
packaged individually plain.
If you open up
those sample boxes there,
that's how our customers
get the doughnuts.
Oh,
so they come plain.
So they all come
like this.
Both: Exactly.
Then you
drizzle yourself.
Both: Exactly.
How long does this last
in the freezer?
So, typically,
we tell our customers
when they receive
their doughnuts,
you store it in the fridge
for up to four or five days
if you're gonna eat them
within that time period.
Otherwise,
they're good for ‐‐
No way this is making it
to a freezer.
You'll eat it
before then.
[ Laughter ]
Marquez: Exactly.
Herjavec: Well, you've sold us
on the taste.
Sell us on the numbers.
What does this cost?
All right.
Our average price
for one box of four is $15.50.
Wow.
Is that a lot?
That's an
expensive doughnut.
It's a lot.
Marquez: Well, if you
compare it to a protein bar
with the similar protein count
is anywhere from $2 to $4.
How much does it cost
for shipping?
So, we charge $5.99 to $8.99
all across the country.
All right,
so about $20, it gets to me.
Ondrea: Yes.
Correct.
What's your cost
on that box?
So, the box
actually costs us about $7.30.
We make about
a 53% margin right now.
Okay,
so it tastes amazing.
Tell us about
your sales.
So,
lifetime sales,
we're super excited to say
we hit $1.2 million,
and this is from
June 10th of 2015 to today.
Wow.
$1.2 million
of doughnuts.
$1.2 million in doughnuts.
Over 280,000 doughnuts sold.
In two years?
Ondrea: Yes.
Cuban: So, where are
you selling them?
So, we sell direct to consumer
all online.
Straight from
your own website or ‐‐
Correct.
Herjavec: What will
your sales be this year?
So we're expected to break
$1 million this year and ‐‐
Why?
What's happening?
Yeah. What is happening?
What's going on?
Ondrea: [ Chuckles ]
Well, I have to ‐‐
So you guys are great
at SEO, basically.
Yes.
Yeah, I have to
give him the credit.
Like, we ‐‐ he's built up
our social media,
and he's made
great relationships
with really great athletes.
And that's helped us a lot
get our name out there.
What percentage of your sales
are repeat orders?
So, this year, we have
a 31% customer returning.
That's remarkable.
Rodriguez:
Good for you.
Sorry. Are you making it
in a commercial kitchen?
Marquez: So...
We have
a co‐packer, actually.
Um, when we started
the business, you know,
two years ago,
Marquez and I were
spending a lot of time
on the weekends,
14‐, 16‐hour days
with his father
making
the doughnuts ourselves.
Marquez, um,
is actually a nurse
and a
respiratory therapist,
but he left the hospital
to do this full‐time.
Love it.
Rodriguez: So, how do you go
from that field
to a protein doughnut?
So, I grew up in
a‐a pretty rough neighborhood.
My father was a single parent
and worked really hard
to just really grind and
put food on the table for us.
And so I've always known that
I wanted to be an entrepreneur
and take care
of my family.
So literally,
we were at the gym one day,
and then a light bulb
just went off.
"Hey, what if we make
healthy doughnuts?"
And the next day, we went out
and bought all the stuff,
and we were acting like
mad scientists making doughnuts.
Wow.
Herjavec: What do you
need the money for?
So, we want to increase
our marketing spend.
We're currently
at a 5X return
on ad spend
with our paid advertisement.
In addition, we feel we can
definitely get our shelf life
of our doughnuts to about
three weeks to four weeks,
which will then, in turn,
decrease shipping costs,
allowing more people
to purchase our doughnuts.
What's next?
H‐How do you exit this?
So, you know,
we feel that next year,
we can break $4 million
with our doughnut sale‐‐
$4 million?
Greiner:
Based on what?
Um, decreasing
our shipping costs
will allow
a lot more people,
as well as
our gluten‐free cake doughnut.
That's something
that we feel
will really
open up the market
to the
gluten‐free community.
We also have a protein
Rice Krispie treat.
Oh.
That is actually
really close to launch.
Great.
So that will easily
take us ‐‐
So you think you're gonna expand
the product lines,
it's gonna bring in
more customers.
I‐I worry about
the price point.
Barbara, when you had
that cake company
that shipped cakes ‐‐
It's not ‐‐
Wait, wait.
It's not
"that cake company."
[ Both laugh ]
It's Daisy Cakes.
I forgot their name.
Sorry.
Okay.
How much was
a Daisy Cake cost?
$49.95
and $18 shipping.
Oh, wow.
And you would think
that would be a hindrance
to selling those cakes,
but they're so damn good.
Marquez: Yes.
Okay.
Maybe price
isn't a problem.
No, this is
a well‐priced product.
Thank you.
And the fact that you have
a 30% reorder rate...
Correct.
...that's phenomenal
in the online‐food business.
Thank you.
It means
that people really like it.
So, Ondrea and Marquez, when
the Sharks are quiet like this,
they usually
smell blood in the water.
While the Sharks
are all circling,
I'd like
to make you an offer.
Okay.                      Okay.
And I'm gonna tell you
why I like you
and why I think
I can help you enormously.
I love the fact that
you bootstrapped your business.
We don't
hear it enough anymore.
You have
such a happy relationship.
It's bouncing off
your skin.
Happy partners
make money together.
And you can't deny that,
right?
I'd like to offer you
the $300,000 for 30%.
Thank you, Barbara.
You're happy
to entertain other offers.
I don't mind that
at all.
But I just wanted
to get that out there.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Greiner: I'll share with you
my thought.
I look at this,
and it's right in my space
for two reasons.
One,
because of Bantam Bagel.
Two, because I really like
healthy foods,
so I've always been
that person
looking for
the healthier alternative,
and this was
really delicious.
Awesome.
I think I actually like it
better than a real doughnut.
Wow.
Whoo‐hoo!
[ Chuckles ]
Thank you.
So, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'm gonna give you
$300,000 for 20%.
Okay.
Ooh.
Cuban: Guys, I see this
as a nice product.
Portion size are small enough
to keep the calories down.
But once you add all the junk
on it, it's still junk, right?
But where I'll give you credit
is your marketing's phenomenal.
Thank you.
So you turned it into
a great business,
but as a single product
I don't really believe in
makes it tough.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Mark.
Um...
I‐I‐I love it.
I‐I don't know if I want
to compete at $300,000 for 20%.
I think
that's a pretty good offer.
I think you've got
two Sharks
that seem to be far more
passionate about it than I do,
and I see a different direction
for it.
So, uh,
I'm gonna clear the deck.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Rodriguez: So let me
first of all say
that I love to do business
with people who have a PhD.
Mm‐hmm.
And I don't mean
from Harvard or Yale.
I mean "poor, hungry,
and driven."
And both of you have that,
so I love that.
Thank you.
In 1994,
I entered the league
as an 18‐year‐old baseball
player for the Seattle Mariners.
In the clubhouse,
Kentucky Fried Chicken,
Burger King, McDonald's.
Players were eating this
45 minutes before game time.
Today ‐‐
Corcoran:
Before a game?
Come on.
Before the game,
right?
Wow.
Today, we have brown rice,
sweet potato, vegetables.
The game has changed
tremendously.
Yes.
So I think
there's a lot of white space,
a lot of opportunity for you
in the sports world.
I'm also in the business
of gyms and fitness.
I own part of 1,000 gyms
in 20 countries.
So, I think, um, with that,
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Okay.
If Lori's up for it, uh,
I'm gonna make you an offer
for $400,000 for, uh, 30%,
and I will share it with Lori
if she accepts.
I would do
that deal.
Herjavec: Ooh.
Cuban:
But would they?
That's a lot of equity.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Ondrea and Marquez
have two offers
for their high‐protein
doughnut company, The Dough Bar.
Barbara has offered $300,000
for 30%,
while Alex and Lori have teamed
up to offer $400,000 for 30%.
Corcoran:
Marquez and Ondrea,
I just want to say something
that I'll point out
out of experience here
on "Shark Tank."
Uh, it sounds lovely
and exciting
when you have two Sharks
swimming side by side,
but my practical experience is
that I prefer to do deals alone,
no matter how capable
my fellow Sharks might be,
because every decision
is made quickly.
I can't stand inefficiency,
and I suspect
you wouldn't have gotten
to where you were
if you were inefficient.
It sounds to me like
you think fast on your feet ‐‐
Well, that's not
a fair thing to say.
You make decisions ‐‐
Yes, it is.
No, it's not.
Definitely it's fair to say.
By the way, Lori and I
have done deals before,
and we're great partners
and we work very well together.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, he handles one area,
I handle another.
And, I mean,
I'm hands‐on.
I do everything.
I'm there
for my entrepreneurs.
You know what? I'll drop down
to 25% to compete.
Herjavec: Yes!
Just ‐‐
And I'm gonna tell you why
because I just feel in my gut
you belong with me.
I know that sounds sappy,
but you're my kind of people.
And even though Lori's
spinning out a good web there,
the truth of the matter is,
you're not her kind of people.
You're my kind of people.
Come to mama.
[ Gasps ]
That's a horrible thing
to say!
I know
it's a horrible thing.
Excuse me, but Alex and I
will drop down ours.
Just because ‐‐
Cuban: Oh‐ho!
[ Laughter ]
That's not
a right thing to do.
Alex, what should we do
about what Barbara just did?
I‐I do think
that 30's the number for me
and is really non‐negotiable,
and I'll tell you why.
I think we're gonna build
a monster for you,
and we're gonna tell you
how to do it.
They don't need your
help building a monster.
Like Lori said ‐‐
They're building
their own monster.
♪♪
Okay,
one second.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
♪♪
Ondrea: Okay.
You thinking?
Yeah,
go for it.
Barbara,
thank you for your offer.
That doesn't sound good.
♪♪
Would there be any chance
you would go down to 20%
for the $300,000?
♪♪
Yeah, I will, just to beat them
out of the box.
Happy to do it.
We got a deal.
Oh!         Oh!
Oh!                          Oh!
Oh, my goodness.
Barbara just crushed it.
[ Laughs ]
Crushed it!
You dropped, you dropped.
[ Laughter ]
We love you guys.
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you so much.
I'm gonna cry.
You haven't
made a mistake.
Thank you.
You'll see.
Thank you very much.
You'll see
in short order.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
Congrats, guys.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh.
[ Voice breaking ]
This means the world.
You know, um,
when we started the business,
it was really
about family.
[ Sniffles ]
And, uh, think about my father
and Mason and Ondrea.
So we're excited.
We're excited
to get this thing going
and really take it ‐‐
take off to another level.
Yeah.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 5,
John Tabis pitched
his online flower company,
The Bouqs,
and left without a deal.
Let's see how he's doing now.
Tabis:
Losing the deal with the Sharks
was certainly disappointing,
but in the life
of an entrepreneur,
there can be no "nos."
So we went out and raised
a $1.7 million seed round,
and we kept growing
the business.
About a year ago,
I pick up the phone,
"Hey, John,
it's Robert from 'Shark Tank.'"
Herjavec: I was planning
my wedding, and I'm thinking,
"Who do I know
in the flower business?"
And I remember Bouqs.
I call up John.
He creates this incredible
arrangement for my wedding.
As I'm learning
about the flowers,
I'm learning about the business.
I decided to take a second look
and invest in the business.
Hey, John,
how you doing?
Hey!
Tabis: Having Robert onboard
has had a huge impact.
When I need help with marketing
or PR or how to run a company,
he's been an amazing asset.
We have changed the way
the supply chain works
from the farmer
all the way to the end consumer,
and we've changed the way
that people shop.
When I had pitched in the Tank,
we had done about $700,000
in sales.
Now 3 1/2 years later,
we've done over $88 million
in revenue.
We've grown from 5 employees
to 60 today,
and we'll be moving
to a brand‐new location
in the next few weeks.
Here it is.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm not the typical
"Shark Tank" story,
but it goes to show you
what never taking no
for an answer can do.
So we brought
the team over.
Champagne?!
I hope that I can serve
as an example
to other entrepreneurs
to never, ever give up.
To The Bouqs Company!
Cheers!
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are former athletes
with a convenient product
to help keep you fresh
at all times.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
I'm Wendell Hunter,
former linebacker, Cal.
I'm Wale Forrester,
former DB, Cal.
And I'm Justin Forsett,
former running back, Cal.
We're from Berkeley, California,
and our company, ShowerPill,
is seeking
a $300,000 investment
for a 10% stake
in our company.
Sharks,
we're gonna let you in
on a little
locker‐room secret.
But please, can you just
keep it between us?
You see,
more athletes than you imagine
don't shower
directly after
a sweat‐drenched workout
or practice,
and we,
three athletes
who take great pride
in health and fitness,
have been guilty of the same
stinky and unhygienic offense
more times
than we like to admit.
Instead of telling you how
a ShowerPill Body Wipe works,
we're gonna show you
with a little help
from former UFC champion
Miesha "Cupcake" Tate.
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
See,
all Miesha has to do
is pull out one extra thick
individually wrapped wipe,
which,
oh, by the way,
doesn't have any parabens,
sulfates, or alcohol,
and simply wipe down
from head to toe.
That's it.
Now Miesha is ShowerPill fresh
and ready to get dressed.
She can be on her way
with confidence
knowing that she won't have
any post‐workout B. O.
or spread any of those nasty
sweat‐related germs.
Miesha,
are you ready?
Miesha: Almost.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Ta‐da!
So say, Sharks,
why don't you come and join us
and be a part...
Oh, I like that.
...of the active care
revolution?
Shower to the people.
[ Laughs ]
"Shower to the people."
That's great.
Wow.
Forrester: Miesha's gonna pass
around some awesome samples.
Oh,
thank you.
I'm gonna
give Lori hers.
Thank you.
So, we've created something
that will nourish
and cleanse your skin
at the same time.
Corcoran:
Thanks, Miesha.
So, did you do any
skin‐sensitivity testing?
Oh, yes.
Have you been through
all of that?
Definitely.
It's hypoallergenic,
pH balanced,
because I suffer from eczema,
so we made the product
for ourselves.
And, Miesha, thank you.
She has to catch a flight.
This was
her ShowerPill moment.
[ Laughs ]
We really appreciate you.
Cuban: Thanks, Miesha.
Bye. Thank you.
Did you all play Cal
at the same time?
Forrester: We did.
Yes.
We all played together.
And did any of you all play
after ‐‐ after Cal?
Forrester: Yes.
Yes.
I'm a former
nine‐year NFL veteran.
I just retired
three months ago.
Congrats.
Pro Bowl running back.
Wow.
What team?
Uh, mostly notably, Baltimore
Ravens and the Seattle Seahawks.
There you go.
Very cool, man.
And he played, too,
as well.
Not quite as notable,
but what I can say
is that I played two years
for the Buffalo Bills.
Cool.
Forrester: And ‐‐
And I was the bench warmer,
and, uh, I took my talents
to the Oakland Fire Department,
where I'm a lieutenant of fire
for the past 10 years.
Good for you.
That's great.
Well‐done.
So I have a question.
What does one cost?
99 cents.
Forrester:
A retail is 99 cent.
It costs us 14 cents
to make.
It costs you 14 cents,
and you sell them for 99.
Yeah,
a box of 10 for $9.99.
And then do you sell a box ‐‐
Okay, a box of 10 is $9.99.
Now, do you have
any sales?
Hunter: Yes.
Since 2014, we've had almost
100% year over year growth
the last three years.
And what is
that number?
What are
those numbers?
Yeah,
what are the sales?
Okay, yeah, last year,
we did almost $300,000.
This year,
we're on pace
to hit 100% this year,
as well.
Next year,
we'll do $2 million,
and the year after that,
we'll do $5 million.
And what's gonna make you jump
from $300,000 to $2 million?
How's that
gonna happen?
You know what?
It was ‐‐
It was really
this decision that we made
to be great.
You know, our vision was
to become this iconic brand,
you know, this, like,
Gatorade of hygiene.
And so what we had to do was
primarily sell on e‐commerce.
We knew we wanted
to expand into retail.
And do you have any deals
lined up?
Yes,
retail we have.
We actually got a letter
of intent from Pharmaca.
It's ‐‐
It's this boutique pharmacy.
Uh,
the airlines.
You know,
we're in talk to be,
you know, on major airline,
uh, you know, also ‐‐
That's smart.
The military.
Military is huge
for us.
Hey, Justin, I have one question
about the numbers.
I'm a little unclear.
You said 100% growth every year,
so from $300,000.
Yeah. Mm‐hmm.
Year two you went to what,
year three you went to what?
Can you clarify that?
Yeah, yes.
In 2016, we did almost 100‐‐
Uh, almost $300,000.
Herjavec: What will you do
this year?
Yeah, this year,
we're optimistic
that we'll hit that again,
but like I said,
we want to ‐‐
Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
wait, wait.
I'm sorry.
Have you
hit it already?
What are your sales year to date
right now?
$200,000.
And so how are you gonna get
to $600,000
by the end of December?
Yeah.
So, what we've done, like,
we focused on
our customer acquisition costs.
We were able to get
our customer acquisition costs
down to 25% of our run rate,
you know.
Yeah.
And as of August,
we had over 30% increase.
I'm gonna go with you
and say that the $600,000
is gonna happen.
I'm gonna be optimistic
with you.
Right.
Give me your earnings,
your net earnings.
What are you guys
bringing home?
'Cause that's how I'm
gonna evaluate what
the business is worth.
Forrester:
Like our gross margins?
Yeah,
we have 60% gross margins.
As of today?
Yes.
All right, okay, so let me
ask you a different one.
Are you profitable?
Yes, we are, but we're putting
everything back in.
Okay, so you're not
burning money right now.
You're not having to put
more money into the business
every month
to keep it alive.
Like I said,
we want to be great.
And so it was important that
we looked at what was working
and we double down
on it.
Herjavec: I‐I'm still
a little confused.
If you sell $100,000
in a single month,
your gross margin
will be $60,000.
What would your net margin be
at the end of that?
Yeah, at that right there,
at $100,000?
Herjavec: Yeah.
We'd be left with that ‐‐
that ‐‐ that, uh, $40,000.
No,
the other way around.
$40,000?
It's the other way around.
Your gross margin ‐‐ Your
gross margins are 60%.
Herjavec: No, no, you ‐‐
you sell $100,000.
Let me ask the question
a different way.
Yes, please.
If the ‐‐ If you do $600,000
this year...
Right.
Herjavec: ...after all
your other expenses,
what are you left with?
That's the net margin.
After ‐‐
After all ‐‐
If we ‐‐ When we do
$600,000 this year,
after all of
our costs...
After all of our costs,
$600,000 ‐‐
You know,
at all of our costs,
we'll be left with ‐‐
You see, so the issue is that
we have ‐‐ So we have ‐‐
You have the 60% margin.
And ‐‐
No, I get ‐‐
But that's gross.
Yeah,
that's the gross margin.
So we take ‐‐
We take the rest of the money
and we put it into
our marketing budget for growth.
Two new SKUs ‐‐
No, you don't.
We have two new SKUs ‐‐
You take some of it
for marketing,
you take some of it
for payroll,
for rent.
Yeah, yeah, which ‐‐
which ‐‐ which ‐‐ which ‐‐
which fuels our growth.
Greiner: So, okay.
No, but what is
the number?
Guys, I'm gonna start
simplifying things here, right?
This ‐‐
Business is a sport.
Yeah, definitely.
Right?
In order to be able
to be successful in football,
if you bust a coverage,
you're gonna get cut.
Cuban: In business, if you don't
understand your numbers
and understand
exactly what your next play is,
you're gonna get cut.
And for those reasons,
I'm out, guys.
♪♪
Hunter: Thank you.
Thank you.
Hey, guys, look, I mean, NFL,
all the power to you.
You guys are
incredibly talented.
I learned
a very long time ago
that I have no talent,
and so ‐‐
And we remind him of that
every day.
[ Laughter ]
So when I went out
in the world,
I just had to
execute better,
'cause execution
trumps talent all day long.
And so I got to believe
in your ability to execute.
Forrester: Mm‐hmm.
And I ‐‐ And I didn't
hear that today.
I'm not saying
you're not gonna get there,
but, uh,
not for me today. I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you, Robert.
We appreciate it.
Thank you.
Corcoran: Let me tell you
what I love about your product
and what I like
about you guys.
Now, first of all,
your enthusiasm is so genuine.
Nobody can sit here without
wanting to do business with you.
Thank you.
The thickness of this,
it's not like a baby wipe
or anything like it.
That was by design.
I don't even think I could
tear this or maybe even cut it.
It's just great.
Okay, all right.
That's what I love.
What I don't like at all
is your confusion.
The numbers
are so totally confused.
I think you probably had
eight or nine opportunities
to talk knowledgeably
about your numbers,
and yet I got more confused
as I listened harder,
and that's a concern
when you're an investor.
I'm out.
Rodriguez: Look, guys, you're
only as good as your team.
What I see for you guys,
I'd love to see you guys
bring in a real experienced guy,
a C. F. O., a controller,
someone who's locked down
with the numbers.
So when Sharks like us
come and challenge you
and ask you numbers
back and forth,
you don't get backed
into a corner.
You're saying, "Wait a minute.
Let me bring in my C. F. O."
Hmm.
So I wish you guys luck,
but for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
So you have
one Shark left.
Come on.
Cuban:
♪♪
Greiner:
Listen, you know, they say,
"Think like a millionaire,
hustle like you're broke."
You guys have been hustling,
and I do think
people will buy this.
I think
it's super smart.
Moms and people around that fly,
campers.
I mean, we could go on and on.
I'm almost talking myself
into this.
Keep going.
This is a really great idea
and product.
Keep talking.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Yeah.
But the reason ‐‐ the reason
why I'm going to go out
is because I know and understand
what it takes
to get a product like this
out there,
so I wish you luck, but I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your time.
Good luck, guys.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
Hey, hey,
it's all good.
It's all good.
We'll get them.
I‐I love the story,
but three of them ‐‐
someone's got to know
the numbers.
They choked
a little bit.
Yeah.
Greiner:
It's true.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a business aiming to solve
a growing problem
for America's college students.
♪♪
Sharks,
my name is Dan.
And my name is Nick.
We are
the founders of ChangEd,
and we're asking $250,000
for 15% of our company.
Shh.
Dude, do you hear that?
There's another shark
swimming in these waters,
a shark that,
no offense,
has more money
behind it
than all of you guys here today
combined.
Dun, dun, dun!
Meet student‐loan debt.
She sits
at over $1.3 trillion.
But unlike you guys,
this shark is taking bites
out of Americans' dreams
and financial freedom.
Sharks,
we all know
college is an experience
you should never forget,
and you won't, especially if
you have to pay for it
for the next 10 to 25 years
after graduating.
It's gonna delay
any goals you may have,
and that is why ChangEd
is changing the way
Americans tackle
student‐loan debt.
And, Sharks,
you remember change, right?
The change you used to toss
in a coin jar
or even
that treasure you found
under your couch cushions
at home.
Today,
we pay with plastic,
but what if I told you
that the digital change
from your
everyday purchases
can help pay off
American student debt?
Now we can,
using the ChangEd app.
Let us show you how it works.
It's pretty cool.
Dan,
take it away.
The ChangEd app
is super easy to use.
Simply create an account,
link your bank,
and ChandEd rounds up
your everyday purchases
to the next dollar.
Robert, let's say you buy
a cup of coffee for $3.45.
ChangEd rounds it up
to 4 bucks,
and you just saved 55 cents
towards your student loan.
All your round‐ups
are stored
in a personal FDIC‐insured
ChangEd account,
and once you accumulate
100 bucks,
we automate a payment
towards your student loan.
Each member
has their own dashboard
where they get to see
their daily round‐ups,
check their
ChangEd balance,
and also see each payment
sent to their student loan.
The coolest part, though,
is they get to see
how much time and money
they save with each payment.
Your average
student‐loan holder
can pay off their student loans
years sooner
and for thousands less
with the ChangEd app.
So, Sharks, who's ready to spare
a little bit more than change
to help Americans
pay down student debt?
What is your average daily users
and your average monthly users?
We launched
in March,
and we have
over 9,000 downloads
and just under 1,000 active
and open FDIC insured accounts,
and we recently ‐‐
which is a really cool stat ‐‐
we sent $20,000 in student‐loan
payments since launching,
and we hope
by the end of this year
to reach $100,000
in student‐loan payments.
Good for you.
We ‐‐
Look,
I‐I think student‐loan debt
is one of the greatest problems
facing this country.
Right.
Right?
There's $1.3 trillion
and growing in student debt.
Yeah.
It impacts our economy,
it impacts people's ability
to go out and get a better job.
Both: Yeah.
It's crazy.
Now, look, this isn't
gonna solve it by a long shot.
Right.
But if you just make it
a little bit easier, right,
then that's a positive.
But from a business perspective,
how do you combat somebody
saying, "We'll just round up
some of your credit card.
We'll round up
some of your purchases.
We're gonna do overdrafts,
we're gonna do student loans,
we're gonna do ‐‐
pay off your house,"
whatever it is,
right?
How do you deal with more ‐‐
more feature‐rich competitors?
We're the first platform
that is specifically targeting
student‐loan debt.
We've learned
over the past few months
how difficult it is
to navigate to apply payments,
so we've
developed relationships
with 90% of the student‐loan
services in this country
to make sure payments
are applied effectively,
efficiently,
and quickly.
The thing
with student loans,
people have
an emotional attachment to them
because it's ‐‐ it's tens
of thousands of dollars
that you borrowed
when you were 18 years old.
Hey, guys, I love the mission,
first of all.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
I think Mark is right.
It's one of the biggest issues
we have in this country.
Tell me a little bit about your
background and why this space.
Yeah, so obviously,
me and Dan are brothers.
He has
the better hair genetics.
[ Laughter ]
But I've got
a solid ‐‐
I've got a solid beard,
and I always claim that.
We're from Chicago.
Hi, Lori.
[ Laughter ]
And we were raised
by a single mom
that told us that we had to
work our butts off
to get
what we wanted.
She immigrated from Poland,
and she worked three jobs
just to keep
clean clothes on our back
and food
on the table.
Going to college,
we had to borrow money,
which kind of
landed us here, right?
We have this problem now,
and we're ‐‐
we're trying to address it
because we feel the pain.
Like,
Dan's living at home.
He's making
a‐a student loan payment,
I think $800
student‐loan payment a month.
I pay $800 in student‐loan
payments every month.
Wow.
Greiner:
Is this your full‐time job?
So, I'm ‐‐
I'm in sales.
I've been in sales, uh,
for about eight years now.
What do you sell?
I sell Mazdas.
And, Nick,
what do you do?
Right now,
I work full‐time on ChangEd,
but what I do
to make money is
I wake up every morning
at 5:00,
drive Uber, and drive people
to work, go to my office.
And then when my day is done,
I go drive people back home,
uh, head home,
and then just, you know ‐‐
You're a hustler.
That's the way you do it,
right?
That's the way
you hustle.
So, like ‐‐
We're not ‐‐
That's what
I'm talking about!
[ Both laugh ]
Thanks, Mark.
But besides that, you never
told us, how do you make money?
How do you monetize?
Yes.
Right now, we charge
$1 a month member fee.
People aren't
balking at it
because they can see
how much they're saving.
How many members
did you have last month?
We're ‐‐
We're just under 1,000,
so I'd say open accounts
were right around 800.
So you made $800
last month.
Roughly.
Roughly $800,
yep.
Dan and Mitch,
I love your energy. Absolutely.
Thank you.
Corcoran:
I mean, who wouldn't want
to come to your party
and play?
[ Both laugh ]
That kind of thing,
right?
Uh, the part that I don't trust
totally, and I wish I could,
is I just can't picture
if I'm a bank
just sitting
on the sidelines
and not rounding up
people's change,
which you're already doing,
and applying it
to the student loan.
I think
it's just that extra step.
But on top of that, it gives
them on trade to refinancing.
For that reason,
I'm out.
All right, thank you so much,
Barbara.
Pleasure.
Thank you.
Hey, guys, I‐I just want to say,
first of all, congrats.
I love the passion.
Thank you so much.
Two brothers,
single mother.
Totally relate with that.
A few things I don't like.
I don't like that you don't have
a real competitive advantage,
and I also don't like
that you don't have a defense
for your competitors.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
All right, Alex.
Thank you for your time.
All right, guys, why is this
a $1.6 million valuation?
As you guys well know, uh,
a company at a stage like us,
the valuation is more
of an art than a science,
but we've talked
to experts ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
I'm just saying.
Greiner:
You're getting creative.
That's the best answer ever!
It really is.
Herjavec: Yeah.
It's very difficult
to ‐‐ to value a company
at our stage, right?
But we're in a market that is
screaming for a solution,
and we feel that we have
the right solution.
Not only that,
we've talked to experts
in the valuation space
that valued our company
anywhere from $1.6 million
to $2.5 million.
And because we know the value
that you guys can bring ‐‐
Herjavec: So, hang on.
Let me tell you something.
I like to paint.
I like to sing.
Mm‐hmm.
I write some poetry.
Yeah.                     Okay.
I'm a bit
of a dancer, too.
So I like to think
I'm an artist.
Okay.
You said
valuations are art.
Here's my stab
at art.
Okay. [ Laughs ]
And honestly, there's lots of
things I don't like about it.
I just love you guys.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
You guys are fantastic.
I think
you're gonna hustle.
But it's brand‐new
and it's early.
I'll give you the $250,000,
but I want 48%.
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
Oh, my God.
Rodriguez:
Highway robbery.
We really ‐‐ We really love
the stroke of your brush,
but we'd love to hear
the other offers.
Greiner:
Okay, I love what it does.
I think
it's very admirable.
It's a huge problem.
It's a crippling problem
for most people.
Right.
On the flip side,
I feel that your valuation
is a little, um, rich.
Oh!
Do you?
So I'm going to go out.
All right, Lori, thank you
so much for your time.
Thank you.
Okay, so, guys,
have you raised other money?
Uh, so we've
bootstrapped this
up until
a couple months ago.
We raised a small
friends and family run
of around $50,000.
Got it. How much have you all
put in yourself?
Uh, I've put in pretty much
my entire life savings
of about $30,000.
And my ‐‐ my ‐‐
my time savings.
I'm spending so much time
on ChangEd.
He ‐‐
He's the sweat equity.
I‐I ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
Me and Dan are all about
smiling, dialing,
walking and talking,
and slaying
and paying down student loans.
Paying down student loans.
We're all about that.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
How do you get your next
10,000 downloads?
Our strategy now is to tap into
the alumni organizations
to reach the people that are
already feeling the pain,
working with universities
and, like, get on the ground
because what we're ‐‐
That's my problem.
I don't see that scaling.
You haven't gone through
the whole
customer‐acquisition program,
which, look,
I like being lean and mean,
but at some point,
you got to start sprinting.
Right, yeah.
You haven't
demonstrated anything
that says
you can sprint.
Convince me
that you guys can sprint.
One of the things
we want to do
with some of the funds we
raised is to develop an
Android app 'cause we're ‐‐
Hey, Nick, if Mark's gonna
make you an offer,
let him
make an offer.
Otherwise, I'm gonna be like
Van Gogh and cut off my ear.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: All right, guys,
I'll make you an offer.
250K for 25% of the company.
What do you say?
Okay.
Is there any room
to negot‐‐
No.
♪♪
So, Mark, we came in here
wanting to get a deal with you
because we understand the
tech background that you have
and how much you can help us
on that end.
But if there's no room
to move on that offer...
♪♪
I think
we got a deal.
We've got a deal.
Done.
All right.
That was
a tough negotiation.
[ Both laugh ]
Congrats, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm cutting my ear off!
Whoo!
Dan: Robert's offer
was a little rich.
Yeah.
But at the end of the day,
Mark's offer made sense to us
because not only was it close
to the valuation we wanted,
we also see value in Mark
as a partner.
[ Grunts ]
Narrator: Next up
is a simple workout accessory
with multiple
potential applications.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Martin Dimitrov.
I'm an entrepreneur
from Chicago.
My company is called SnapClips.
I'm seeking $150,000 in exchange
for 15% equity in my company.
♪♪
SnapClips are the most durable,
safe, and user‐friendly
weight collars on the market.
As many of you may know...
weight collars are used
to secure free weights
to a barbell.
But the problem
with normal weight collars is
that they're not durable,
they're not user‐friendly,
and they're not safe.
Greiner: Wow.
♪♪
SnapClips solves
all these problems.
Remember those bracelets
that kids used to play with?
SnapClips work the same way,
except each clip contains layers
of heat‐treated steel reinforced
by military‐grade kevlar,
so it's a little different.
But snapping them on is easy.
Hold them like this.
You clip them onto the bar.
And you lock them into place.
Wow. Easy.
Our silicon‐on‐silicon grip
securely holds the SnapClips
against the weight.
And our added Velcro lock
seals the deal.
Good idea.
♪♪
Rodriguez: Wow.
Corcoran: Wow.
♪♪
That's not going anywhere.
[ Chuckles ]
And once you're done
with your lift...
♪♪
...take them right off,
and you straighten them out.
Yeah.
Greiner:
That's amazing.
It's that easy.
Great idea.
Wow.
Good for you.
SnapClips are changing
the fitness industry,
but the best part about
having an issued patent,
aside from it being cool having
an issued patent at my age...
[ Laughter ]
...is that I can license the
technology for other purposes.
Anything from
industrial fasteners
to telecom companies
looking to secure cables.
This is just the beginning.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to make some money?
Wow.
Cuban: Good for you.
Can we see them?
Dimitrov:
Yeah, absolutely.
And how old are you?
I just turned 19 this year.
Greiner: Wow.
In August.
Wow.
And you
thought this up when?
Uh, when I was a junior
in high school.
Wow.
Cuban:
Good for you.
Herjavec:
Put your hand out.
No. [ Laughs ]
They're actually ‐‐
They're pretty strong.
Martin,
are you still in school?
Uh, I'm actually
going to college right now.
I'm a sophomore at University
of Illinois at Chicago.
Wow.
They really are strong.
♪♪
[ Gasps ] Wow.
That's scary. That's strong.
So, yeah, it was something
that I came up with
in a high‐school class,
and, uh, we actually
also did a Kickstarter.
We did about $23,000 in a month
with no advertising
while I was in high school.
Martin, so let's say
you get an investment.
Is your plan
take some of that money
and hire somebody
full‐time?
Are you gonna drop out of school
for a couple of years?
Yeah, I‐I mean, school's always
gonna be there to take my money.
[ Laughs ]
I'm ready to go
both legs into this.
So you'll quit school and go
into this business right away?
Yeah.
♪♪
Martin,
what do you sell them for?
The retail is $29.99.
For one?
And what do you
make them for?
$8.50.
For the pair.
And what are your sales,
Martin, for this year?
This year, we've done $6,500.
Keep in mind that we did
only launch a month ago.
6,500 units?
Uh, dollars.
Dollars.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah.
That's it?
But last year,
we did $23,000 in a month.
It was actually about $25,000.
Some people
missed the Kickstarter.
Martin, how did you come up
with $1 million valuation?
So, we did about $25,000
in sales on Kickstarter.
A couple trickled in
after our Kickstarter ended.
So, you know, I'll say
that we did that for a year.
That's about $300,000.
And you multiply that by 2,
which I've seen some valuations
being done like that.
So that's about $500,000
right there, a little bit over.
And then I value the patent.
I‐I actually value it
at over $1 million,
but humbly, I would say
it's valued at $500,000.
Have you gone
to any other industry?
Yeah, so,
I actually know one of a ‐‐
a couple industry leaders
in the wire‐management area,
and they were really interested
in the patent
because of how it could be used,
you know,
just for storing wires
like this.
So, you know, you just ‐‐
This is just a SnapClip,
but, you know,
we'd make something
a lot more cost‐effective,
and you could just hang it
like this.
And it saves a lot of money,
and it's so much easier
because it's reusable.
I mean, honestly,
that's what I see
is everything
with this.
I mean,
I don't know that much
about the weights in the gym
and all of that,
but it seems to me
the application of this
is fabulous for any type
of hose ‐‐ garden hose...
Yeah.
...wires, utility,
whatever it is.
That's everything.
It's just
marketing this,
like,
getting it out there.
That's ‐‐
That's why I came here.
That's the hard part.
Herjavec: Martin,
let me start.
I‐I think
it's a great product.
I think you're incredible
at 19 years old.
But I think
this is a bit of a journey,
and you got to get into
the other markets
for it to be interesting
to me.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Corcoran: Martin,
you're the right entrepreneur,
no doubt.
Nobody here would doubt you
for a second.
It's just not a product
I relate to,
which is the reason I'll go out,
as well.
Thank you.
Listen, I'm ‐‐
I'm gonna give you a flier.
Okay.
'Cause my thought is that
the patent's interesting.
But I'm thinking of a million
other things to do with it
than what you actually
came in here
thinking about
the weights.
Here's the way I would
structure the deal.
Okay.
I would do $150,000...
50%.
50%?
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Martin is seeking $150,000 for
15% of his company, SnapClips.
Lori is interested,
but she wants
50% of the business.
Herjavec: 50%?
Greiner:
50/50 partners.
And I'm gonna
tell you why.
You're 19.
You're in school.
You have a lot
ahead of you.
to do.
Uh‐huh.
This is a clever idea,
and you have a patent.
But somebody
has to come in
and take this
from ground zero...
Turn it
into a company.
...and turn it
into something big.
And that's a lot, a lot,
a lot, a lot of work.
Now, I've done it
with our Simply Fit Board,
with other products.
We've done hundreds
of millions in sales.
But you don't get that
without really putting in
an incredible amount
of work,
which is why
I'm offering,
if another Shark
wants to come in with me.
I'll take that deal.
♪♪
Wow.
Two Sharks.
What do you think
about that?
Uh, I mean, I think the equity
is a little bit high.
I‐I don't want to give up 50%.
That's kind of crazy
just because of how much work
and the potential
that I see in it.
You think
it's a little bit high?
[ Laughter ]
He's being polite.
Greiner: Well, I've had
several entrepreneurs
where they were your age
or a little bit younger, even.
They didn't know
how to deal with packaging,
retailers, licensing.
I agree
that it's difficult,
but I've done everything
up to this point.
I designed everything,
so I‐I feel like, yes,
it is a big undertaking to make,
uh, you know,
the products under ‐‐ all the ‐‐
Okay, Martin, let me ‐‐
let me try to simplify.
What would you counter?
Let me hear
what you would counter.
Forget the counter.
Okay, look,
it does take a lot of work,
but you deserve a ton of credit,
all right?
I think her offer of 50%
is ridiculous.
I would never tell anybody
to take that.
Now, 15% isn't enough,
but I do think Alex and Lori
could add some value.
So here's my offer.
I'll convince these guys
to come in,
but it's 150K for 30%.
Let me explain to you
what I'm thinking here.
I get
in the trenches,
and I grind
with my entrepreneurs.
Mm‐hmm.
If I now have
these two amazing partners,
then I'm sharing...
The work.
...some of the hard work
with you.
That I'll accept.
I would then
go down to 30%.
Alex, look, I'll bring the
Mavs in. We'll put a Mavs logo.
We'll put it in there.
We'll get other teams
in the NBA.
It'll go from there.
Alex,
you bring your gyms in.
I am in
if he stays in school.
I agree. I'm not doing this deal
unless you stay in.
♪♪
All right, deal.
Done.
All right.
Done, done.
Corcoran: Great deal
all the way around.
Rodriguez:
Nice job.
Thank you.
Partner.
Awesome meeting you.
Thank you.
Congrats.
Smart.
Smart man.
Thank you.
Excited.
It's good stuff.
Good stuff.
♪♪
We had
an amazing entrepreneur,
but he did $6,000
in sales
and you gave him a
half‐a‐million‐dollar valuation.
Not taking anything
away from it.
But the value
of the patent ‐‐
Let's just say
it's a first.
But ‐‐ But the way I look at it,
what I value ‐‐
For me, it was all about
the ‐‐ the patent.
Yeah, would I buy the patent for
500K and take my chances on it?
Greiner: Yeah.
Yeah.
♪♪